I'm at the premiere of between two ferns
the movie and yes the interviews got
just as weird as the film do you really
I don't I don't
oh wow thank you do you like or your is
it real it's real you don't mind Kelly
here maid Kelly this is this is nice
really nice touch is it okay to eat I
don't want to okay I'm very hungry but
also a milestone birthday is there any
meat in this Oh sausage it's a sausage
cake we're told that was your favorite
boy that's rich yeah do you have a
burger yeah I did yeah I have one coming
up I know that I'm not promoting some
dumb book that's why there's so many
yeah my birthday is coming up thanks for
pointing out that I'm almost 50 look mom
I'm bobbing for turds I'm 50 I'm almost
50 I still do that though where were we
between two ferns the movie is this
gonna be it is it going to be in
theaters not in theaters not in theatres
the celebs definitely don't know what
you're about to ask you know I don't
know we don't give a either questions
cuz we need them to naturally squirm
nobody's that good of an actor No and
that makes it difficult sometimes for me
because I'm like in real life I would
I'm not
I don't like rudeness rudeness is funny
but in real life when I see a rude
person it drives me crazy and I think
that's what this character is is just
making fun of read people I want to know
when I'll call to with
that's a good one I think it's not a bad
movie no it's one of my favorite movies
so we've talked about I know it's not
it's it's actually the shelf life on
that is not bad I mean who doesn't like
a snowboarding movie with Lee Majors in
it
yeah yeah we did talk about that are you
Canadian that's nice yeah you seem just
nice maybe where you from what are the
nicer States